[Music]
hello I'm Paul F Tompkins this is a
bowtie this is a lie I'm going to show
you how to tie a bowtie and then you're
going to know here's what you do you
have your boat put it around your stupid
neck okay and under your shirt collar
button up your collar be nice then pull
the right side down once so that the
left side will be half the length of the
right side you will cross the right the
long end over the left the short end
like so then you will flip the long end
over like this right tighten it let it
drop down this is easy so far you're
barely doing anything I'm mad at you
then this back part you're going to take
it like this Lipper over like that this
is where you're making the bow you see
the magic is revealed everything is
eliminated hold the bow like this will
the back part like this let the front
part
flop over then you are going to bring
these ends together fabric here the back
part you're going to push this through
the little hole that you have created
behind the boat did you see the little
hole see there's that thing in there
right that's where the bow goes through
push the fabric through the little hole
I'm trying to give you a good angle on
this because a lot of tutorial videos
I'll show you that it'll be very
frustrating and then you'll end up with
a repetitive stress injury in your arm
like someone who is me pull the
alternating sides back front three ends
and the closed loops
well then back and forth to make small
adjustments tightness of the knot it's
okay if it looks a little sloppy that's
how people know that you actually did it
like a real big boy or a girl
that's your bow tie I did this without a
mirror and you can too once you got it
you've got it for life it's just like
smoking cigarettes which I'm assuming
you're doing or should be just kidding
that's for dumb people I hope you
learned something and that's something
that I hope you learned is how to tie a
bow tie because that's what I was trying
to can get you to do I follow Tompkins
and this has been an at midnight
masterclass
[Music]